children crush fallen leaves with their
feet they live at an orphanage near the
capital Katmandu
school exercise books are recycled to
writing an omok and knox
news this year new materials are made
from old the ground-up leaves are added
to this mix of water and paper it's not
exactly a high-tech process but it works
these are biomass briquettes the
orphanage is funded by private
contributions and doesn't have the money
for firewood we need a lot of money to
buy food and to buy tree just like a
waste of money tree and wood and so we
were searching for a new substitute of a
wood so the briquettes replace wood for
heating that helps protect the local
forests which is an important source of
oxygen and provides a home for many
animals it's tough in the environment
and the year will be polluted and it the
environment will be bad in such a peace
environment the orphanage is located
near a Brickyard which burns through
wood supplies at a furious pace it's
also the largest employer in the village
the Brickyard takes up a lot of space so
did the farmers fields there's not much
room left for trees in fact over the
last 25 years Nepal has lost about 1/4
of its forest land
this orphanage is home to nearly 60
children Yamada and Suresh Conti care
for the kids almost as if they were
their own the couple's own two children
live here too on the roof of the
orphanage there's a makeshift
drainage chute for collecting water and
solar thermal equipment for heating it
it's a high-tech solution that provides
the orphanage with hot water the
orphanage recently installed two small
units that contain solar modules for
generating electricity now we can read
at night and now we can watch TV get it
TV area now just a mother that's it it's
time for dinner sometimes they do have
to use firewood but the biomass
briquettes provide enough fuel to heat
two small cooking stoves the briquettes
are actually a better fuel than wood for
several reasons
Haidee products hidden they catch fire
more quickly and generate more heat and
there's less smoke to taught us and
jolly is a widow she lives at the
orphanage with her two children but she
also looks after Roux puck and the rest
of the kids the children are hungry sand
jelly serves up dad bot a traditional
Nepali dish made of steamed rice and
cooked lentil soup Suresh and numata
also provide the children with spiritual
nourishment this includes regular prayer
sessions and singing the orphanage is
run on Christian principles and the
couple tries to reflect their values in
their everyday lives I try to be like a
mother to these children I do everything
I can to show them a mother's love we
raise the children we prevent them not
to become a street children and we are
providing them a good education and we
make them to learn and law
these girls are preparing their lessons
for the following day it's not easy to
study when there are 14 of you living in
one room but at least there's enough
electricity to keep the lights on
the electricity comes from solar powered
batteries that store sunlight over the
course of the day the batteries power
the lamps the children use at night when
there is no electricity we we read on
candle know now here is solar light we
always studies here's another potential
source of energy the orphanage owns four
buffaloes and they create a lot of
manure there are small user friendly
plants that will convert that manure
into methane gas they're made are around
50 kgs of Khaldoun each day and if we
can reuse them as a biogas then we can
have a biogas to cook food the children
at the orphanage lead active lives and
these new alternative sources of energy
have helped them to expand their
horizons and they've learned new ways to
work together to help save the
environment